[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants beaux soirs tiens
qu'est ce que j'entends le téléphone
sonne en bas j'ai sûrement pour moi j'y
vais patrons ou les châles
j'avise hommes
alors monsieur nicolas l'appareil à
l'eau
alors nicolas qui vient te televen à
l'envers
donne moi je téléphone nicolas merci à
l'eau dieu est à l'appareil salut je
peux venir y avait
demandé vous de la partie mais c'est
camille charigot à l'eau michaud il
fallait le dire que c'était corps du
flan un lot vient cornichons on t'attend
rien il a raccroché
mais c'est parce qu'il va aller vite
près dans la maison d'un ami aux non je
n'ai pas parce que votre amie arrive
qu'il faut tout mettre des gens
michaud aussi nous mettions dans la
salle de bain c'est l'anti 2 je crois
qu'il n'aime pas bien si on était
prévenu le plus simple est de tout
mettre sur la table cornichons choisir à
l'endroit où il veut dormir d'accord
je vais chercher l'oreiller et moi la
convertir n'oubliez pas les draps
[Musique]
aux
ceux qui le touilleur
convertir
on a de la veine cornichons d'avoir des
amis qui la prendre c'est qu'on s'amuse
bien avec lui ah ça oui il est drôle que
leur tir à temps j'ai mon ravenne où tu
as réveil nicolas
[Musique]
c'est juste il fait tu pas
les enfants une part
et cornichons qui n'arrive pas allez
vous coucher et vous la tendre et où lui
tu as raison nous et je garde mon réveil
[Musique]
tu ne sais pas lire l'heure nicolas
tu vois il est pas
moi aussi j'ai sommeil les enfants
savent et dormir nous nous on attend
quand michaud je vais peut-être leur
encontre rue tu lui diras qui est
dépêchée oui aux
deux
pourvu qu'il arrive dit
alors tu viens nounours je regarde si je
la perçois pas cornichons qui doit
arriver ce soir chez nicolas et
pimprenelle
mais je ne le vois pas ne t'inquiète pas
ses parents l'accompagnent en roulotte
et ne se perdra pas en route il arrivera
demain
alors à demain cornichons à demain les
enfants allez vite vous coucher
est fait pour
e
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]